(elevator ding)
(cheerful ukulele music)
(people exclaim)
- Puppies!
- Little babies!
(overlapping interjections)
(speaking audio sped up)
- Hi!
(squeal)
- I'm so happy right now.
(speaking audio sped up)
(high pitched laughter)
- Hey, can I come in?
- Yeah.
(excited voices)
(speaking audio sped up)
- Oh my god!
(voices overlapping with excitement)
- Hi baby!
(speaking audio sped up)
- Oh! This one is such a fat guy.
(excited clamor)
(speaking audio sped up)
- Somebody pet this guy!
I don't have enough hands!
- Oh my god!
- He's so beautiful!
(speaking audio sped up)
- Hi little guy!
- Hi!
(giggle)
- Are they neutered?
- I'd find one...
- What is this for? Just fun?
- Yeah.
(overlapping conversation)